on en parle depuis des mois on a extrait
du recyclage qui est en pleine crise
au canada les centres de tri qui
débordent on sait plus quoi faire de nos
matières recyclables naughton de verre
de plastique parce que la chine n'en
veut plus les philippines n'ont plus
alors pour trouver des solutions
la communauté métropolitaine de montréal
tient depuis hier une série de
consultations publiques sur nos fameuses
maintien résiduelles gens pensent matin
avec louise et nous étiez qui est chef
des projets scientifiques à la fondation
david-suzuki bonjour bonjour alors
l'objectif de la cmm c'est de recycler
70 % du papier du carton du verre et du
métal
est-ce que vous jugez que c'est réaliste
compte tenu du contexte actuel
oui c'est réaliste c'est ambitieux mais
pas tant que ça si on considère que
depuis 1989 on s'était fixé des
objectifs de détonner 50% les matières
recyclables de l'enfouissement donc une
d'année en année on reconduit des
objectifs très similaire avec peu de
croissance
moi je pense que la cmm dans son nouveau
plan de modification du plan de gestion
des matières résiduelles c'est aussi
donner les moyens d'arriver à ces
objectifs là on pourra changer beaucoup
de choses dans tout cas pour y arriver
parce que quand on regarde les tout
derniers chiffres de recyc-québec 14% du
verre et 18% du plastique sont recyclés
pour l'instant quelles sont les
recommandations que vous avez émis dans
vos dans votre mémoire qui a été déposée
hier après midi
le mémoire qu'on a déposé hier
après-midi en fait souligne le fait que
plusieurs des recommandations qui
étaient mises de l'avant par la cmm
elles mêmes vont dans le bon sens ok on
parle dans un premier temps de réduction
à la source c'est certain que peu
importe la modernisation du centre de
tri qu'on peut faire les nouvelles
technologies pour le recyclage si on ne
réduit pas à la source
on n'arrivera jamais à ces objectifs là
ça veut dire de toujours se demander ce
qu'on en a réellement
besoin si on pense dans le code d'un
publi sac est ce que c'est réellement
nécessaire que chacun des ménages la
communauté métropolitaine de montréal
reçoivent à chaque semaine cinq cents
grammes de publicité dans un sac de
plastique peu importe que ce soit clos
soit recyclable que le papy qu'il
contient soit recyclé est-ce que c'est
nécessaire on vous dit quoi que le
publisac devrait de bani non le publisac
devrait simplement à être envoyées aux
clients qu'ils veulent en eau au canada
une loi anti pourriel si vous ne voulez
pas être sollicités ce contre votre
volonté dans des courriels ben vous avez
le droit
on croit que le courrier par la poste
devrait être la même chose si vous ne
voulez pas recevoir un publi sac à la
maison vous y avez droit et ce devrait
pas être votre responsabilité d'apposer
une étiquette pour dire je ne veux pas
de publisac ça devrait pas être votre
devoir si vous le voulez de vous
inscrire pour recevoir le demander quand
vous dites les faut se demander si on a
besoin d'un produit quelconque parfois
on a besoin du produit mais pas du
suremballage qui va avec souvent dans
les magasins donc l'utilisation du
plastique le plastique à usage unique
qu'est ce que ça fait partie de vos
préoccupations à la fondation
oui tout à fait dans le monde dont
environ la moitié du plastique qui est
produit qui sert à usage unique c'est
absolument aberrant donc il faut
absolument s'assurer que l'on réduise le
plus possible usage des plastiques à
usage unique et là où ils sont
nécessaires qu'on intègre un fort
contenu de matières recyclées dans ces
plastiques à usage unique là donc ça
vaut vraiment forcer la mise en place
d'une filière de la récupération et de
recyclage pour qu'ils soient réutilisés
dans des produits
est-ce que vous avez abordé dans votre
mémoire la fameuse question de la
consigne pour le verre les bouteilles de
vin ouais bien entendu la consigne la
majorité des québécois sont favorables à
une modernisation ce système là qui a
été mise en place dans les années 80
déjà donc la modernisation de la
consigne sur le vert pourrait passer par
langlement de matières qui n'étaient pas
visés en ce moment donc les bouteilles
d'eau pourrait diviser les bouteilles de
vin pourrait aussi l'être
il pourrait y avoir création de centres
de dépôt pour facile que les faciliter
le tri et la gestion de tous les
commerçants qui à l'heure actuelle gère
la consigne pour l'ensemble des
québécois
donc la consigne est une façon d'aller
chercher des matières très propre et
aussi une façon d'aller chercher des
matières qui peuvent être remplis
réutilisées donc le but de la consigne
c'est pas seulement de collecter de la
matière propre pour avoir une meilleure
capacité de la recycler ensuite mais
c'est aussi de collecter une matière qui
éventuellement pourraient être lavés et
réutilisées et sociales diminuent
drastiquement l'empreinte
environnementale de non motorisés sont
tous des bonnes idées mais en même temps
il ya la confiance des gens sur laquelle
il faut travailler j'imagine parce que
on l'a vu dans les dernières années il
ya très peu des matières de ce qu'on met
dans le bac qui finalement est recyclé
l'eau sont autant du verre et du
plastique et ça ça devient j'imagine un
cercle vicieux
oui il faut comprendre que du côté des
fibres comme le papier et le carton ou
du côté du métal les taux de recyclage
sont vraiment nettement supérieure du
côté du classique en me disant je sais
que le gouvernement autorise la mise en
marché de plastique qui ne sont pas
recyclables ou qui ne sont pas
facilement recyclable donc par une
responsabilité élargie des producteurs
avec un ajustement des tarifs qui sont
chargés et pris en considération par éco
entreprises
il pourrait y avoir moyen de ne mettre
en marche et que les plastiques qui sont
réellement recyclables en bout de ligne
et là on verrait les taux de recyclage
augmenter drastiquement et vous avez bon
espoir que la cmm mettre en application
les différentes recommandations vous
avez fait tout à fait parce que la cmm
c'est 50 % de la population du québec et
on est vraiment un gros joueur c'est
important il ya des actions qui sont
faites au niveau provincial et ces
actions là
vont déboucher dans des solutions
concrètes sur la modernisation de
l'industrie la récupération et du
recyclage dans les prochains mois donc
les constructions publiques se
poursuivent à différents endroits dans
la communauté métropolitaine de montréal
au cours des prochains jours est louise
et nos métiers merci début novembre ce
matin merci merci bien